Evet ne güzel burada olmak hayatımın en
heyecanlı günlerinden birisini yaşıyorum
Az önce oturduğum yerde şunu düşündüm
daha geçen hafta dublin'de konuşurken
şimdi kendimi tedex konuşmacısı olarak
gördüm Bunu o kadar çok hayal etmiştim
ki bir tedx konuşması hayatımın hiçbir
döneminde olamamıştı çok yaklaştığım
zamanlar olmuştu Ama onun için Atatürk
Lisesi size minnettarım
Meryem Meryem beni aradığında Belki de
hayatımın en güzel davetini aldım ben
size bu kısa sürede
Niğde Aksaray topakkaya'dan boş sonra
götüreceğim
Kahramanmaraş'a bir ara döneceğiz
geçireceğiz
size kendi hayatımı anlatacağım ama
anlatırken önce hem okul müdürünün
yöneticilere Benal Hocama sevgili
öğrencilere onlarla tanışma fırsatı
buldum iki yıldır Hayat kurtarmayı
beraber çalışıyoruz biraz kendi hayatımı
anlatacağım ama içinde bol da bilgi
olacak
ve de bütün bunları kalan
18-16 dakika içerisinde bitirmeye
çalışacağım
aslında bir konuşmacı için en zor saat
kan şekerleri düşük
dikkatler dağınık akıl kahvem odasında
esneyenler bol
diyabetliler çok
salonda 100 kişi varsa yirmisinde
İnsülin direnci olduğunu biliyorum
İnsülin direnci deyince bana Vizyon
veren Marks var olimpiyat şampiyonu
1972 Olimpiyatlarının 7 altın madalyalı
şampiyonu muhteşem bir hikayesi var Ben
de o yıllarda lisede yüksek katlıyorum
sırıkla yüksek atlıyorum İyi de
derecelerim var aslında Mark Speed
Tip 1 diyabetle hem insülin yapıyor hem
reflüsü var
kendisini tanımaya başlıyor
kendisini tanıdıkça ne zaman
performansının düştüğünü
ne yaparsa insülini ne zaman vurursa
başarılı olduğunu ne zaman başarılı
madalya kazanacak hale geldiğini daha
20'li yaşlarda öğreniyor kendisini
tanıyor
kendimizi tanımamız bilmemiz vücuttaki
belirtileri anlayabilmemiz o kadar
önemli ki O sayede hayatta kalabiliyoruz
ilk olimpiyat şampiyonu 7 dalda altın
madalya aldı
Max yüzme dalında
Münih Olimpiyatları
2005 yılında Pekin'de Michaels 8 altın
madalya alana kadar bir olimpiyatta en
çok madalya kazanan sporcuydu
fanusunu kırmıştı Tip 1 diyabeti vardı o
günkü koşullarda Aslında eski
teknolojiyle tedavi oluyordu ama
yarıştan önce yemek yerse ağzına
geleceğini biliyordu Onun için birkaç
saat önce yemeği öğrenmişti
Ben de hep onu taklit ettim yüzmedim ama
sıçradım iyi bir yüksekçiydim
1979 yılında Amerika'da North
öğrenci olarak değişim öğrencisi olarak
gittiğinde
lisede Amerika'nın ilk iki yüksekçisiyle
karşılaştım Koçum bana sen çok kısasın
dedi
Sen yüksekçe olamazsın dedi Oysa 2
metreyi geçmiştim burada
sıçramam çok iyi olduğu için
sen dedi uzun atla bakalım dedi Evet
uzun atlamada da 6 metreyi geçtim ama
o bana başarı getirmedi
yıllar sonra Türkiye Cumhuriyeti Sağlık
Bakanlığı'nın bir burs programı için
mülakata gittiğimde
Amerika'da ne yaptın sorusuna ki bakan o
zaman Rıfat Serdaroğlu
müsteşar Aysun çıraydı
onlara Amerika'da atletizm takımına
girdiğimi anlattım başka dediler
futbol oynadı başka
Annem Luis foller çok iyi bir gönüllüydü
Ee
Aslında hazırlanmamıştım bunu ama
nedense Mülakatta anlatmaya ihtiyacı
duydum
ne yaptım dedi gönüllü olarak annenle
Amerika'da arkansas returarak da
1980 yılında
o bölgenin en fakir insanları ile
tanıştım
annem bir hayır kurumunda çalışıyordu
bugünkü o Excel dosyasını kağıt üzerinde
yapıyordu ve benim işim fakir aileleri
evlere girip gözlem yapmaktı tuvalete
giriyordum sabun var mı Banyoda Şampuan
var mı kıyafetleri nasıl
dolapta neleri var Uzun bir liste
dolduruyorum
bunu anlattığımda bu hikaye beni Türkiye
Cumhuriyeti Sağlık Bakanlığının burslu
hekimi olarak Amerika
ve bir yıl süreyle Amerika Birleşik
Devletleri'nde meyve kliniğinde Aile
Hekimliği ve acil hekimliği konusunda
çalıştım
acil birinin başındaki Fransız
meslektaşım yıllar sonra
beni boş sonra davet eden
ekibin içerisindeydi Evet
Neyi de Aksaray topakkaya'da başlayan
Hikayem boş sonra gitti
Niğde Aksaray topakkaya'da mecburi
hizmette Bir Yandan Bir yandan da Tıpta
Uzmanlık sınavına hazırlanırken
teneke soba var
odun yakıyorum
karbonmonoksit zehirlenmesinden de
korktuğum için Çünkü sessiz kokusuz bir
gaz kolayca zehirlenebiliriz ölüp
gideriz kimse anlamaz intihar etti
zannederler camı da açık bırakıyorum
Soba yanıyor cama çok soğuk bir mevsim
Aralığın son günlere yine kapım çaldı
her akşam olurdu bu
boş Doktor Bey hoş
onu kurtaran ama nasıl bağırıyor
ateşler içerisinde
O oyunda Ben arkada Yarım metre
yol açmaya çalışıyoruz onun kapının
önüne getirdiği traktörün arkasına bindi
biraz böyle görüyoruz Belki biraz
tutturuyorum evine var Neydi Aksaray
Topak
eski Başbakan Yardımcısı Medeni Berkin
Köyü ilk mecbur hizmeti yaptığım yer
evine girdik Bir havlusu var üst katta
yatak odaları var Oraya yöneldim Ah bir
baktım Adamcağız girişte sola yöneldi
bir başka yere gitti
ahıra girdik
kızım dedi
Yerde yatan bir inek
Ben bilmem dedim ben inek bakmayı Bilmem
ben onu muayene edemem bir yandan da
kafamdan şunlar geçiyor
ya
böyle ciddi bir hastalık varsa ya salgın
olursa
orada Karantina var Karantina koşulları
neydi Ay ben o derse girmemiştim yeni
mezunum Karantina nasıl
nereden okuyabilirim kime sorabilirim
kapanmalı mı Ne yapmalıyım bunları
sorarken Ben anlamam dedim bir veteriner
hekim bulmalıyız dedi doktor bey bu
saatte veteriner hekimi Nereden
bulacağız Aksaray'a gidemeyiz yollar
kapalı bak İşte buna ben dedim nereden
nasıl bakılacağını nasıl muayene
edileceğini Bilmiyorum desem de bir
yandan elimin sırtıyla
eğilip muayeneye başladım Gerçekten de
ateşi yüksekti
alev alev yanıyordu
ben anlamıyorum desem de ya öksürüğü var
mı ishal oldu mu bugün değişik bir şey
gördün mü diye bilgi almaya başladım
Hocam dedi hiçbir şey yok dedi
birdenbire ateşlendi yattı dedi sen dedi
böyle bir çocuğa insana ne yapıyorsan
aynısını yap dedi Ve gerçekten yaptım
en büyük enjektör içine depo
ateş düşürücü vitamin
bir yere saplı
ittirdim gitti
mutlaka dedim veteriner Görmeli yarın
sabah erkenden veterinere göstermelisin
döndüm
Ertesi sabah
saat
10.30-11 civarı
poliklinik sırasında bu adamı
elinde
iki Bakraç yoğurtla görünce İşlerin
yolunda olduğunu anladım
doktorun sunduğu hizmetin karşılığında
yumurta yoğurt gelen dönemleri yaşadım
aslında Çok da keyifli günlerdi
Evet
veteriner hekime gitmiş balık onu
getirmiş sabah veteriner hekim hastayı
muayene etmiş Tabii inek ayağa Kalkmış
ve veteriner demiş ki Doktor bey lütfen
selamımı söyle ne yaptıysa neye
başladıysa onu 15 günlük tedaviye
tamamlasın demiş
Hayatında ilk defa bir ineği kurtardım
doğal olarak onun ailesinde kurtarmış
oldum ve poliklinik defterlerimiz Vardı
bizim eskiden o deftere hasta adı
Sarıkız
yaşı 3
tanısı Üst solunum yolu enfeksiyonu
tedavi reçetesi verildi
ve böyle bir hasta mı oldu
bu hikaye Yıllar Sonra
Marmara'da depreminden sonra ekip olarak
Türkiye haritası Derneği olarak o
bölgede gösterdiğimiz yararlı çalışmalar
nedeniyle
ve benim de dernek başkanı olmam
boston'da Amerikan acil hekimleri
birliğinin Onur üyeliği
başarısını getirdi bana ve o ödülü almak
için bostana gittiğimde
karşımdaki 5000 kişiye ne anlatacağımı
düşünürken düşünürken düşünürken Sarı
kızın hikayesini anlattım Biz acil
hekimleri herkesin hayatını kurtarmaya
hazırız Öyle ki bakın meslek hayatımın
hemen başında böyle bir vakayla
karşılaştım dedim
ve çok büyük ilgi gördü
o kongrede
cerrahisin bizim en prestijli
dergilerimizden birisidir editör kendi
köşesinde editör yazısı olarak Bu
hikayeye yazdı
Sarıkız topakkaya'dan bir kış günü benim
karşıma bambaşka bir hikaye olarak geldi
hayatım içerisinde Aslında
bambaşka hikayeler o kadar çok oldu ki
hayatımda
2011 Van depremi Van Erciş depremden
birkaç gün sonra bölgeye gittiğimde
Japon bir hekimle arama kurtarma
ekibinin lideri olan aynı zamanda Hekim
olan
mikayasa ile tanıştım
mikayasa yine sorumluluk alabilen
hayatını hiçe sayabilen Hayat kurtarmak
için kendisini feda etmeye hazır olan
meslektaşlarından bir tanesi yine bana
vizyon verenlerden
aynı bak Kim o gibi o da Çernobil
Faciası olduğunda gece nöbetçi amir
büyük bir tesis
risk altında ama insanlar daha büyük bir
risk altında diye düşünüp o tesisin
sular altında kalmasını sağlayarak
yüzlerce insanın kurtarılmasına neden
oldu bir başka kahramanım da o
Mikail ile tanıştım Erciş'te çok kısa
bir konuşmamız oldu
sonra İzmir'e evime döndüğümde şunu
öğrendim
2011 Van depreminden sonra
Bayram gelmişti
bütün arama kurtarma ekipleri çekilmişti
ama
mikaiasse kalmıştı bölgede
gönüllüydü
görevliydi ama gönüllüydü
Bayram otelde kalıyordu
5.4 büyüklüğündeki bir artçıyla bayram
otel yok oldu ve Mikail orada kaybetti
ama Türkiye'de Anıtı olan dünyanın dört
bir tarafında afet tıbı deprem
konuşulduğunda hep anılan bir kişi
olarak kaldı o da benim hayat kurtaran
kahramanlarından bir tanesi Aslında
hayat
kurt ama benim dedeme
isimli veren dedeme ilham olan
Selahattin ülküme Antakya doğumlu
1943 yılında rodos'a atanıyor baş
konsolos savaşın tam göbeği
estağfur'un Yahudilere nefes aldırmadığı
bir dönem
Ülkümen
başkonsolos 50 yahudiye Türk pasaportu
vererek onların hayatını kurtarıyor
geçtiğimiz yıllarda İsrail'e haifa'ya
bir NATO toplantısına katıldım toplu
yaralanma yönetimi konusunda görev almak
için Eğitime katılanlardan bir tanesi
senin adın Ülkümen dedi Evet dedim Sen
Selahattin hükümeti tanıyor musun dedi
biliyorum dedi
O benim babamı kurtarmış dedi rodos'ta
ve dünyanın ne kadar küçük olduğunu fark
ettim
Hayat kurtarmaya başladığınızda Dünya
sizin için o kadar büyük hale geliyor ki
sorumluluk alabilirsiniz kaçmayın
sokakta
yardıma ihtiyacı olan bir köpek mi
gördünüz Susuz kalmış
ya da bir yaşlı mı gördünüz karşıdan
karşıya geçmekte zorlanan ya da
gözünüzün önünde nöbet geçirip bir yere
yığılan birisini mi gördünüz ya da göğüs
ağrısı çeken birisini mi gördünüz ya da
Kahramanmaraş depremini ona benzer
büyüklükte bir depremle mi karşılaştınız
Mesleğiniz işiniz ne olursa olsun
durun bakın yardım edin size çok iyi
gelecek
bedeninize çok iyi gelecek çünkü
bir insanı kurtaran bütün insanlığı
kurtarmış gibidir hepinize sevgi
saygıyla selamlıyorum İyi ki varsınız
Sağ olun var olun